від неадекватної особи яка поплюжить
збройні сили України Ну я не тряпка
якась ну що ж цей час настав Чим менше
мене чутно тим менше у нас всіх Потім
проблем друзі всіх вітаємо це Верховна
Рада України і останній цього важкого
23го року пленарний
[музика]
тиждень5 на поляга 26 На жаль ми не
встигли завершити розгляд питань порядку
денного на сьогодні
що немає журналістів у парламенті що
навіть канал Рада не висвітлює роботу
парламенту Ну а займається чим завгодно
знаєте це для чого потрібно для
деморалізації До речі каналрада був один
з небагатьох допущених до
прес-конференції президента Зеленського
і навіть там спромоглися сформулювати
питання не про парламент не про те що й
досі тут засідає опзж заборонена партія
це дуже складно там є дефіцит пороху
тощо багато різ питань фактично немає
монобільшості ніякої тому що жоден закон
не приймається голосами сьогодні слуг
народу Ну немає
Ну але задали питання про ментальне
здоров'я ви згадали про дружину пані
Олена окрім багатьох напрямків Якими
вона зараз опікується особливо приділяє
увагу ментальному здоров'ю психологічній
сті вона зробила Це пріоритетом і ось за
це з бюджету парламенту
виділяється 275 млні гривень у мене
немає грошей 500 млрдв у Мене попросили
у середу Верховна Рада України прийняла
кілька дуже важливих законів які
перезріли навіть в першу чергу це зміни
до податкового кодексу яким було
скасовано ПДВ для ввезення імпорту або
виробництва в Україні обладнання
радіоелектронної боротьби системи реб
треба налагодити виробництво реб я
Нагадую що моя команда інвестувала 150
млн грвен в розробку нової технології
яка вже зараз садить орлани і суперками
нам потрібно більше свого виробництва
потрібно більше ввозити системи РЕ
звільнення від сплати податку на додану
вартість не тільки ввезених радіо радіо
локаційних приладів а і тих які будуть
вироблятися в Україні кінцевим
отримувачем цих товарів
є відповідно до сертифіката кінцевого
споживача всі підрозділи які зараз
захищають Україну Це дуже важливо Це
класна новина що 323 нардепи
конституційною більшістю проголосували
ці закони в цілому і ми сподіваємося що
Президент Зеленський оперативно х
підпише не тряпка якась адже наприклад
уже кілька місяців Зеленський не
підписує закон так само прийнятий
конституційною більшістю
про списання швидке якщо більше там
вірніше менше на 100 000 є втрати
військової техніки чи обладнання в першу
чергу мова іде про дрони Ну ви також
зрозумійте мене у мене немає таких
повноважень традиційно парламентський
тиждень починається з виступів
представників фракцій і якраз Порошенко
розповів про свій останній візит на
фронт Сьогодні підранок я повернувся з
фронту і
сказати про те що там не вистачає
снарядів нічого не сказати це те що
кажуть наші бійці сказати що не вистачає
проти повітряної оборони нічого не
сказати і ми маємо зробити все можливе
для того щоби прискорити надання від
наших партнерів цієї допомоги
і держава має налагодити серійне
виробництво всередині країни ще раз
закликав негайно відкликати з
профільного комітету з нацбезпеки і
оборони неадекватну депутатку про
очищення комітету з нацбезпеки від
неадекватної особи яка поплюжить збройні
сили України Ще одне дуже важливе
рішення ми внесли зміни до Законів про
адміністративну процедуру в першому
читанні рішень в цій сфері але ми маємо
завжди пам'ятати що диявол в дрібницях
тому тут потрібно не забувати що має
бути увага дуже прискіплива до всіх норм
щоб не вийшло так що проводячи абсолютно
правильне в цілому рішення ми не
створимо наприклад корупційних ризиків
от важливо до другого читання тут
допрацювати ті норми які можуть звузити
повноваження місцевого
самоврядування обмеження тут тих
можливостей які має Російська Федерація
Тому що ті норми які зараз прописані На
жаль створюють таку небезпеку тому до
другого читання будемо доопрацьовувати
взагалі це біч нинішнього парламенту
коли намагаються ну чи не в кожному
законі просягти щось Що звужує
повноваження децентралізації люди бачать
як я бо як я
працюю як я служу Україні і парламент
підійшов до таких важких дискусій щодо
законопроекту про легалізацію медичного
канабісу Ну що ж цей час
[музика]
настав дивіться От коли ідуть
обговорення зала порожня знову хоча мова
іде про абсолютно принциповий для країни
законопроект сумніву дуже дивує той факт
що зараз Як і завжди під час обговорення
таких важливих резонансних
законопроектів це відбувається в
порожній залі і це яскраве свідчення
незацікавленості народних депутатів
України багатьох розібратися про що
йдеться Сподіваюся в залі 50 народних
депутатів Ми щойно порахували всіх
депутатів які зараз знаходяться в цьому
залі і нарахували аж 71го депутата
насправді наша фракція подала кілька
принципових для нас поправок Якими ми
будемо наполягати на посиленні держа
гу за виробвом і обігом медичного
канабісу цей закон ключовий Він має
вирішити питання доступу пацієнтів до
ліків але ніяк не бізнесові питання але
ніяк не питання обігу незаконного Я
хотіла би щоби дійсно комітет
максимально був готовий пропрацювати з
колегами ті застереження які ми маємо
стосовно необхідності реального контролю
за обігом
цих речовин прозорих і зрозумілих
доступних для всіх правил які будуть
функціонувати і які впроваджує держава
щоби ми не відкрили скриньку Пандори і
під абсолютно правильним гаслом допомоги
пораненим і допомоги тим хто потребує не
відкрили безконтрольного виробництва і
Для нас це принципова позиція бо чим
хибує цей проект це те що в одні руки
віддано виробництво контроль на нагляд і
подібні речі позиція нашої фракції є
однозначною очевидно що онкохворі
паліативні хворі наші військові які
мають посттравматичний синдром повинні
мати право на достатнє лікування і
медпрепарати з використанням канабісу і
насправді уряд давним давно мав би це
зробити своїми підзаконними актами але
краще закон аніж його відсутність в
залежності від того чи будуть підтримані
ці наш поправки будемо визначатися з
голосуванням Це добре Да дуже важливо що
ми працювали із громадськими
організаціями які якраз підтримують
легалізацію медичного канабісу і вони
стоять теж на наших поправках шановна
Ірина Володимирівна ще раз підтверджую
що біль більшість поправок від вашої
фракції були дійсно фахові тільки
медичний канабіс тільки жорстке державне
регулювання цієї сфери дуже важливо і на
ми
291 не наполягаю 292 не наполягає
293 Чим менше мене чутно тим менше у нас
всіх Потім проблем на саме голосування
відбудеться вже у четвер На жаль ми не
встигли завершити розгляд питань порядку
денного на сьогодні друзі підписуйтеся
на наш YouTube канал тут правда про
роботу Верховної Ради України яка На
жаль сьогодні працює не прозоро і це
абсолютно не
відповідає зобов'язанням України яка іде
до ЄС і НАТО парламент має бути сильним
незалежним і працювати 100% прозоро для
всіх українців